hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play hello
I'm getting out of here alive basic
there's an asteroid loaded up in the
mining Bay waiting to be smelted oh ho
if you attach the SOI speak into it you
can launch it away from the ship to make
a clean broadcast does it have dye meter
then the maintenance sub deck you can
launch the asteroid from the control
room
damn the control room is locked it looks
like they keep an emergency access key
on the processing sub deck uh-huh can't
be easy could it no of course not I mean
how much more of this I can take you can
take what have you even done
you've been huddled up in your little
safe room I've been out killing hundreds
and hundreds of these monsters just
everywhere good great I like her she's
just whining Oh tough it up sister
I'll bet oh thanks thank you
now I got eight oh so many target
all right this looks ominous we got here
great Kosh sensitive electronic devices
all right out of the crate more bullets
give me though gimme here we go a bench
all right um the only reason I haven't
upgrade my help so far is because
there's there was two empty nodes in the
beginning but I got so many notes it
don't even matter let's that's upgraded
twice and I'm still left over with -
booyah amaz boo oh let's see here we go
Oh store
I don't need a store I just came out of
the store Oh get the way I see you I see
you Marian you're in here obviously I'm
stupid hello and hello all right
and that's that all right
what music got a little dramatic here
that was weird like all of a sudden the
music was acting like something was
happening and it was nothing I guess
it's just trying to miss alright yeah
that was it I didn't what am i doing
wasting time that's what I'm doing
elevator more elevators man too many
elevators wha huh whoa buddy I got a med
kit I don't think it'll grow your arm
back foot you held out just long enough
to let me see your money subject is
offline for some reason Isaac yeah I'll
see if I can run a bypass always follow
mining deck procedures must mine sorry
my minecraft is coming through okay
processing maintenance how do I know
which one I'm gonna do wait hang on wait
when you get out here um where's my
journal find Kendra located the mining
access key on the processing sub deck
that must be where the mining supervisor
died I knew these men I can't believe
they are all dead he knew these men how
oh oh he's an engineer a DA okay that
beacon could be the only way off this
goddamn ship hi watch your mouth young
mister stored somewhere on the
maintenance stick okay so I need to get
the key first so the processing sub deck
is where I need to go okay process okay
sorry buddy this was probably his friend
ah was that hi
no no no odd no saw that coming
don't you're not good who wants some oh
don't cry ha what hello Oh how'd you get
in front of me
nope anymore
anyone else want to say hi ha who's
there punky cat doll give me your items
all your items that's right that's what
I thought
didn't even work ok that's why oh there
there I was wondering what the
differentiation between their uniforms
these are these are mining uniforms
people because those are the same
uniform
ok it's starting to make sense but a
little bit more sense I still don't get
this whole virus thing but it's cool if
you temple hey it's tough there isn't a
single space worthy vessel in the whole
goddamn bay hurry up we need to find a
vegan
there's gotta be one around here
somewhere well they had the same idea
that we did and obviously the Legion
could not get along so
that plan didn't work out dead bodies I
don't trust you
ah no
[ __ ] up leg down
go home don't buy me hahaha yeah oh so
hold it I'm like all kinds of awesome
ah
give me wha ha what's that boom hey what
the hell oh give me here give me your
head boom ha ha I can't believe that
work put behind me ha ha [ __ ] you're
surprised you feel now and these big
these big ones used to give me like a
superconductor or a semiconductor what
happened but I'm too all their goodies
I'm gone I'm sad one goodies don't trust
you sorry if you were a friend of
Isaac's I don't care I don't trust you
don't trust yo gimme your goodies
goodies goodies love me some goodies all
right where the heck am I going
honey don't know this way that way oh by
the save station I don't need to save oh
I just noticed like my back there's more
dots I guess that means you know my
health got upgraded whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I know hi there how you doing buddy
you doing good good I haven't seen you
in about a few seconds you jumped out
anybody up nope ah you almost got me you
think I got this pole drive
stuns the crap out of you oh and so so
what I want to know is wow you have half
your face on there you really do look
kind of human there what I want to know
is why there's so many dead guys around
that aren't turned into zombies I think
that's a stranger thing then the guys
that are turned is up why wouldn't they
all be zombies by now like how long ago
did this start that there are still dead
bodies I mean I remember seeing before
there were some of those monsters
dragging bodies away so anyway
don't worry about it the situation here
just got a lot worse the gravity failure
came as we were collating the asteroids
and one broke free of the grab beam it
collided with a wall killing two crew
and split into chunks they're
free-floating in the processing room and
we can't restore gravity to get the
master key until they're cleared we
could really use some engineering help
up here Wow things just bad happen all
over the place up here I guess this is
one of the asteroids I did
all right oh goody gimme I see it yeah I
know there's a mess get there I want
that one thank you thank you very much
okay in here entering steps
oh hello buddy sorry but I found the
processing control door it won't open
Aero gravity is restored oh you can turn
on the gravity until those boulders are
cleared from the room well doesn't that
sound into that gravity being with your
Kinesis gun will travel whoa huddle
who's there I heard something oh whoa
then I saw
was that where-where-where up there I
don't see jack ah ah come on
howdy not cool bro not cool where oh
right there right let me now get out of
here
I'll come on die kind of a monkey want
to go waste all my bullets I hate you
have any control given her loss yes area
must be cleared okay I get it I get it
again
Oh yep Ruby oh yeah
killed beans
good thing I'm rolling in pairs okay um
get in just
it rocks okay there we go
anomaly it's a meteor sound nullus
anomalous materials that's was it
I see a box have it no not you buddy
sorry
I want box I hear something who's there
who wants some ah baby baby no no no no
okay gimme am that's a good baby
give me more animal mo than you take all
right is that everything is that
everything I don't see any more i clear
the darn gravity oh no I heard that
oh whoa where hello where oh man oh
there's no I can't there's no gravity
biggest message
ah
where where oh my goodness I can't see
there Oh seriously let's grab no gravity
is mescaline hardcore Oh
what what good why would you flip like
okay I need to restore gravity please do
oh please give me gravity good it would
suck to jump through that be
problems
there we go okay oh no oh no wow you
died quick close that deck a big one
you're right with you Zack adds an
exploding come on boom bang II all right
all right now's your turn I'm gonna kill
you both kill you fall
ah darn that can't shoot the I can't
shoot shoot through that thing
boom gone odd darn it
released all of you yes mine example
ocean Kazuki
all right done nope we're not oh hello
legs gone
right a ball
wha-what
what the hell one of those exploding get
me dammit where'd you come from that
then oh no damn it
I'm old Oh
I gotta use my fourth med kit oh that
didn't even do it again
I use my fifth net get God that is do
nothing why you know he'll good all
right I'm probably using little one
sense this way ah that's fine that's
good enough I'm fine all right I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye bye